Wait, what?
I mean, like, we're not...
Why is my mic so low?
So...
My mic is actually not low.
Do not make it large.
No, no, I'm on my...
On my OBS.
I'm on OBS.
It's, like, low on my OBS.
It's, like, at the yellow.
It shouldn't be at the yellows.
That's the thing.
The yellow...
It was supposed to be at red, so they die, or what?
Yeah, no, it's supposed to be at the red.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
Yeah, it should be, like...
touching the red so it's like it's no wait actually let me
see yeah it's so low it's almost at the green i'd be always
at the reds that's the red is the bad one no it's good it's
good when you're you're the streamer it's guys just a little
messy at the moment wait my son okay can someone tell
someone wait i can tell tell tell ditto to hop right in we
need a hop in her channel because her channel is the live
channel we're in general oh yeah we're in general wait
where's my disc grade where did it go i'm a mess right now
guys i'm okay i'm so tired you're a mess it's you're tired
it's 2 a.m like
i'm tired i'm tired she's tired guys but it's 2 a.m here
let's start your idea how was i supposed to know it's in
japanese i couldn't it can't read that I know that means
live.
Okay, I'm hopping in.
Hey.
Hello?
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Wait, where's RPR?
RPR is not hopping.
Okay, RPR.
RPR is late.
Yeah, he's late.
What is he doing?
Yeah, where are you doing?
You're late.
He's in game.
Yeah, you're wasting our time.
Hey, what's up, Dito?
I feel like, why were you late?
We were waiting for you.
I just needed a moment of silence.
You need a moment of silence?
Why?
Yeah.
I just need to breathe in.
Breathe out.
Okay, so like, this game is all about coordination, but
like, we have, we have, each person is from a different
region.
So, I don't think that's it.
it's gonna be the problem here just gonna point that out how
is that not the problem i don't think pink is gonna be our
biggest issue 100 ping is gonna be an issue what do you mean
yeah it's definitely gonna be an issue because whatsoever
whatsoever is this uh na it's and okay yeah yeah i want to
say um we're playing with no checkpoints apparently yeah no
i said maybe should do baby mode and then like our pro is
like no because chat's gonna bully us if we play baby mode
so was i wrong i'm seeing a nasty girl i'm just seeing that
like i feel like we might need baby mode with the ping we
have so all right so are you guys are you guys excited have
you guys played this yet i have no this first time i have
first time first time okay so I am so happy that you guys
are going to be the first people I'm going to play this game
with.
I'm so excited to get this going.
I played with actually competent people, so I know what it
was like to, like, you know, actually progress before I play
with you guys.
Okay, good.
Pause.
What do you mean by actually competent people?
Who are these competent people compared to me?
People who live in NA.
No, even the sound guy was like, did you turn your sound?
down you sound so quiet i know sound guy there's something
weird with my mic right now i don't know what i don't know
why i sound like more quiet than usual i should have i don't
know why it's so weird my shit is like fucked up for some
reason um i'm gonna put myself at 100 maybe that'll be
better i'm putting myself at a hundred uh i have no idea why
i'm like more quiet than usual my my set my setup no i meant
like on obs like on obs it's like for some reason my obs put
me at like the yellow when i'm usually at like the red so
yeah like when i'm talking it's not at the reds right now
and it's usually at the red so it's okay not supposed to be
in the reds you're not supposed to ruin their fucking
hearing when you're streaming when you're when you're the
streamer when you're the main character of your stream
you're supposed to be at the red and everybody else is
supposed to be at the yellows like oh yeah who made this
rule who made this rule streamers made the rules all right i
pushed myself up a little bit maybe i should restart my my
uh my go xlr give me a sec guys i just need i'm gonna
restart my my go xlr real quick all right we are so prepared
for this call out this is so important look i'm saying i'm
making sure oh my god it's easy my god i can't hear you i
can't where did you go you walk away from the mic this game
is not that hard it okay somebody's coping right now um wait
okay yeah no it's easy this game's easy all right okay so
i'm gonna put myself at 100 because apparently i don't know
what's going on with my looks okay are you guys ready yes
are you guys you guys are ready right yes yes okay i'm
playing i'm prepared yeah let's get this pain train all
right all right what's about oh god okay i need to oh my god
this is my most sensitivity yeah it's it's bad it's bad i
want to look at you guys deto is fucking old all right i'm
gonna i'm home list right now all right give me a sec i'm
saving my settings don't worry guys i'm care i'll carry
don't worry yeah yeah you're carrying us carry us yeah carry
us yeah carry us yeah also i hope i was i i was then here um
follow you guys okay me too she's she's useless we didn't
even start man but we're wasting time let's go guys look we
have a timer top left we're already 40 seconds
speed running let's go come on we are gonna get speed done
why do we need a speed run we have to work together what is
this what is this stop stop it's like only up for
multiplayer that's basically you don't even know what the
game is it's oh yeah it's only okay okay okay it's easy
because okay obviously we're not gonna beat the game so like
what's the goal what's the all right What are you doing?
I'm gonna trust my...
I'm gonna trust my Discord.
You pull it up.
How do I pull it up from there?
Jump!
All right.
Just jump!
I turned down my Discord.
I turned down my Discord, guys.
Yeah.
Okay, guys.
Let me crack my knuckles.
So we have to jump here.
Okay, you guys ready?
Okay.
Jump.
I'm ready.
Okay.
You guys are not ready.
You guys are not ready!
You are killing us!
You're killing us!
I said are guys ready!
All right.
jump jump jump what are you guys doing together together
we're gonna do one two three jump every single time okay no
bullshit we don't need it one two three jump oh you're like
oh stupid Okay.
Ditto, you jump on two.
You jump on two.
Okay, Ditto.
Okay.
One, two, three, jump.
Oh, okay.
Ditto, I see you jump on two.
No!
Maybe...
All right, ready?
One, two, three, jump.
Why do we just jump one, two, three for this?
Oh, my God.
Okay, okay, okay.
One, two, three, jump.
Ditto, you're always the one behind.
Ditto.
No, I mean, be like, be like, I have like, I have like, I
have like three of us.
It's a kindergarten we're gonna start.
All right, I bet you when I look behind, that is gonna be
the one in the very back.
If you fall down and you pull me down with you, I will...
Give me a watch.
They don't get over here.
Get the fuck here.
I just wanted to know what I can We go right, we go right We
go right Give me one good reason to go right Okay, jump One,
two, three, jump Because it's literally faster If I touch
this, do we die?
If I touch this, do I die?
No, you don't die, you don't die in this game You don't die
in this game So why is the laser here?
It knocks you off It's a fake laser Yeah, yeah Follow me,
follow me No, it's on the right It's on the right Can you
see that fucking Bowser shit?
The Super Mario shit.
It's the same shit if you go left or right.
What are you on about?
It's closer to go this way.
Listen, what is this?
It's Super Mario.
It's Mario.
Oh, okay, okay.
You know what?
Doki, you can IG.
No, no, I don't want IG.
I need to turn down my Discord.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
All right, I'm ready.
Okay, no, no, no, no, no, no.
As the oldest person here, you have the IGL.
I'm 12.
No, 13.
Is this Dr. Disrespect?
Are you...
Oh, my God.
I don't want to talk to you anymore.
What are you doing?
No, no, no.
Pull me, pull me, pull me.
Okay.
That's a jump pad.
Wait, let's do it.
Wait.
Okay, wait.
Okay, second bounce we go, okay.
Second bounce.
We go to the other side.
This is the second bounce.
the second bounce okay okay one more time the second bounce
okay okay here we go here we go
the second bounce right here go go go go go wow great i'm
gilling keep it up all i'm saying is i have yet to fail as
an igl chat i'm not banned i'm not bad my hope i hope i get
bad oh my god he admitted he was 12 years old he's not
allowed on twitch report him they literally have my
government information they have my government information
okay right side right side right side right side right side
go you're pulling me back how much no you cannot say i'm
pulling you back you have to be specific because it's not me
look at who's at the furthest back and it's not me
okay now i don't remember there i skip here i don't remember
where you go i think it's all so far no no you can't you can
you just just keep jumping backwards two steps are you are
you kidding me are you are you kidding me i'm in pr are you
what did i do i sat still you didn't pull us up man yeah
it's just maria bro how is this my fault you fell i wasn't
moving i wasn't moving you pulled me and you fell what do
you mean how is it me how is it me give me one good reason
how that was me because when you fail i fail and then you
fell first you learn you know what you're on twitch somebody
clip rpr falling first which i'm bad i'm bad somebody clip
him right now clip him of him falling off first and then tag
him and me and i'll retweet it
why i sign up for this shit i'll also clip him say that he's
i don't know you try okay okay okay wait wait wait wait wait
okay go this is why we should have went beginner this is
exactly why i don't know why we're not in beginner we're
fine look at the skip we just how are we fine we almost fell
the amount of time it took us to pull each other back it's
wasted our well you're falling because of you you need you
need positive mental attitude oh yeah i'm not positive here
i'm not the positive you know what we should let ditto lead
us we should let her lead us yeah you're doing great you're
doing great you're doing great you're doing great too
no did i signed up no i what did i say you said yes you said
yes focus up focus up focus up focus up Walk the chain.
Walk the chain.
Focus up.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm fucking focused up, but you guys are pulling me down.
Right side.
Speed run this.
There you go.
Speed run.
If it's a speed run, why are you guys so slow?
Speed run right here.
Right side.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
My god.
You know what?
You're right.
I know what I'm doing.
I don't know about you guys.
Well, you can't do anything that we don't do because we're
people play this game solo some people play this game solo
which i don't understand why because it's like it's like
it's basically only up i guess it's because you guys know
only up is like removed from steam so they play this as if
it's yeah it is it's removed from steam so they play this as
if it's only up i beat only up at a record world time okay
somebody's fucking yeah you're lying all right dido how long
how have you was better than both of you how long you've
been a wake ditto 15 hours oh my god guys she's been playing
powwow for 13 hours guys stop pushing stop pushing you can't
push anybody there's no collateral there's no no collision
there's no collision here what do you mean stop pushing me
you can't push anybody you can't push anybody You can push.
No, you can't.
There's no collision.
Stop pushing.
You're like, you literally are like so far away from me.
How can we push you?
All right, here you go.
Wait, where are we going?
Where are you going?
Right side, right side, right side.
It's always right.
How do you know right side?
It's right.
Because I looked at the fucking bones.
What do you mean?
How do I know?
You look, use your eyes.
So if this leads to nothing, like, who do we blame?
Okay.
How many gifted memberships?
How many gifted?
I don't got money.
You're not going to get money out of me.
You're a fucking millionaire.
Like, why are you...
I am not a millionaire.
Have you not seen my fucking re-debut?
Just because you spent your money doesn't mean you weren't a
millionaire before you spent it.
All right.
Here we go.
Second bounce.
Wait.
Where are we going?
Second bounce.
Here we go.
Right here.
Here.
You guys ready?
We have to go straight.
All right, who's doing the countdown?
Now, go now, now.
Oh my...
Oh, my God!
Jump!
Clamp it, climb it to the right, climb it to the right,
climb it to the right, climb it to the right.
Drop on the bottom one, drop it to the bottom one.
Now climb, jump over, jump over, jump over!
Deep down!
Okay, this is it.
This is easy, man.
Easy.
How did that work?
She was simple, dude.
Why are you panicking?
She wasn't even hard.
How did that fucking work?
I didn't get...
Oh my god.
But she wasn't even hard, dude.
We beat it.
Alright, ready?
Oh my god.
No, what is this?
What is this?
Oh, I don't know.
Who did that?
Get off the ledge!
who did that who did that who was it above me rpr what did
you do rpr oh i didn't do how is it my fault that you guys
did that would you i saw you're really the only one with a
different skin than us you're the last one you guys are like
what is this somebody clip it somebody clip it on rpr's
channel and then tag me and then i'll retweet it i'm gonna
turn my stream off I don't even want to be here.
I will retweet every mistake he's made.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Just get up here.
Let's go.
Okay.
Get up.
Okay, here we go.
What are you guys doing?
Oh, my God.
What are you doing?
No.
What do you mean?
What are we?
You literally just walked off.
Wait!
Dude, it's just like, oh my god.
You think you should wait for us?
Yeah.
Why don't you wait for us?
The only reason Dita's hating on me is because you're here.
If you weren't here, she would hate on me.
No, she would obviously hate on you.
No, dude.
You corrupted her.
No, no.
We are not hating you.
We're just criticizing you.
That's different.
Okay.
First house.
One step from hate.
second jump second jump second jump second jump okay we go
one line okay okay we go instantly instantly run okay yeah
yeah what the what does that work That's how it is.
You're playing with a profession, okay?
That should not work.
Alright, we're okay.
Everything.
Okay, now I don't know what to do here.
We just dodge the spikes.
Wait, wait, wait for the spike.
Okay.
Are you trolling me?
Pull me, pull me.
What are you doing?
You fucking climb!
Jump!
I'm first!
I'll go first.
Okay.
Wait.
Alright.
Bro, what happened to go?
What?
What did you know?
I saved it.
We all have the...
What do you mean you say the time?
We all need to go at the same time.
We need to go at the same time.
Wait, wait, wait for me.
Wait for me.
Right here.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Okay.
We're learning, but it's a learning process.
why are you why are you saying to be mad we're getting
what's in here what's in here it's like okay we don't care
we don't care we don't care okay all right go go go i don't
think there's any more spike there's no spike here all right
yeah we should be good there's no more spikes okay okay
who's doing three to one who's doing it one line in one line
okay it has there's only one ride comes we go okay next time
it comes we go okay but who's counting down now go oh okay
oh we almost thank god oh we're fine we're fine we're fine
no perfect all right ready three two one go okay nice three
two one go why could you do that earlier for the first one
go look at us we're a team one go we're a team guys we're a
team okay now we obviously have two choices we should do
this one what is this
can we even is this even a choice no i don't think that's a
choice it's not even a choice
What's your down here?
Okay, oh.
Oh, you're going to jump over this.
What are you guys doing?
Why are you guys doing?
Why are you guys looking at it?
Three, two, one, go.
I was just admiring the view.
Ah, I'm too strong for one, three, two, one, go.
Yeah.
Three, two, one, go.
Okay, look at that, guys.
My god.
Perfect.
We should be a team guys.
Where do we go?
Oh.
Up here.
And then what?
Okay.
And then up here.
There's a ladder.
What?
How are you supposed to see this?
We did all that.
And there was a ladder.
in my defense i was cooking where were you cooking clearly
it wasn't anything it's lazy listen we have to jump okay
ready okay walk with me walk with me yeah oh god oh no look
at me there were spikes too grab this ledge grab this ledge
what's that there's spike
like why did we play normal why didn't we do baby mode okay
you don't you think that our chat would let us fucking play
nothing but normal we just don't tell them we just don't
tell them you think they don't know this game they know more
about this game than we every time we drop off we turn off
our stream and we hide our screen every time we turn and we
drop off and then Bye.
For scientific purposes, what is your title?
My title?
What do you mean?
It's a stone chain together with Doki and UPR.
Wait, what was the title?
What was your title?
Wait, I want to know where your title was.
What was it?
Just read it.
Should I take a screenshot?
Chain together with me.
I'm chain together with Noki and UPR.
I don't know.
Wait, what were we supposed to look at?
It says chain together with lovely dokey and um the handsome
rpr yeah that's what it says yeah it says that what were we
we're supposed to look at what what do you see yeah what do
you see what do you see oh nothing don't worry guys i'll
just show this what what is it what is it see i told you
it's not gonna flame me yeah why are you What are you doing,
RPR?
RPR!
RPR, what are you doing?
Guys, how is this my fault?
I didn't even move!
RPR, why are you throwing?
Why are you...
You need to move so we fall, okay?
Yeah!
We're clearly trying to do something here.
We're trying to be gamers and you're like...
Ah, let's go then, let's go, go.
Three, two, one, go.
go three two one go wait why are we jumping on one are we
jumping at go go why can't we jump on one it's easier
because it's three to one go is obviously you jump on go
because why i don't know because like because like sometimes
you guys are yeah see just we don't need to do three to one
is the beginning okay you wish to say go every time yeah by
the time we hear go the pain will yeah you would jump
because of pain i bet you if you just say go we'll be so
coordinated why am i i jelling all right watch this go see
look go go go go go go go go go go go for this i would hope
look at us
go we're so good all right come on ditto all right second
jump second jump we can jump okay second jump okay all right
second jump here here now we go go go go go go go go all
right second jump second jump okay go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go guys good job good job look at that
Keep moving.
Okay.
Guys, I think we're gamers.
Yeah.
I think we're doing really well.
Wait, did any of us actually beat only up?
I said it was easy.
I beat only up.
Don't beat somebody.
Wait, you beat only up.
Then why are you so...
I think I beat only up like under an hour.
I'm pretty sure.
Then why are you struggling?
I got less than an hour.
I beat it in 30.
minutes that was my speedrun record dokey dokey i am chained
to you you understand that is why i suck right now i i had a
speedrun record of 30 minutes no you didn't yes i did you
you're the liar here you did not beat it under less than an
hour yes i did there's there's walls where's the proof
where's the proof in the vods like what vod why would i lie
did is he lying yeah he's lying
You see what you did?
I don't know.
Even my chat that's never on my side is saying he did.
There's a word.
My chat was like he's lying.
Okay, but your chat's wrong.
My chat's wrong.
Go.
Okay, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
See, look at that.
It's that easy.
Over here, it's not good to lie.
It's not good for your heart.
Oh.
How?
How can you come so fast?
Because I'm good.
Because I have legs.
I have.
Why are you so slow?
Ditto.
Come on, we're fast here.
Okay.
To be fair, the ping is not as bad as I thought.
Are we okay?
I don't think ping matters in this game.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go.
Okay.
We're okay.
Stop.
so wait okay go go go go go go we die together we fuck up
okay there you go see look at that okay is that easy move
move move speed run only speed run what even is the speed
run for this i wonder i'm sure what's the speed run i mean
we could literally look at look at it my chat said it was
under 45 minutes okay so this is like a eight hour game then
go Oh, only up Wait, wait, wait Okay, pull me?
Okay, perfect Okay, yeah, yeah Okay, go Go, go Go, go Go, go
Why are you singing a ping after me?
Go, go, power rangers Okay, up here Okay, let's Let's wait
for the next ship Okay, I'm waiting If I could push, I would
push you I was just thinking if I could punch in this game
Holy shit okay we don't need call-outs for this this is like
your own uh your own adventure for that okay up here ready
ready go go how come whenever you say go you wait like two
seconds and then you jump yeah because i i have to
all right all right let's not let's not get fucked here i
don't know what Okay.
Oh.
What?
What's that?
So it's a laser and then it spikes.
Okay.
It's because we touch the laser.
If we touch the laser, we drop off.
Oh, yes.
So we don't touch the laser.
We will be okay.
So jump over the laser and then jump over the laser again.
Okay.
Why?
Right here.
Jump.
Go.
Oh, my God.
You're crazy.
Not even close.
Not guys.
Give me a sec.
I need a grab the coffee.
Okay, I'm ready Okay Which one?
Oh no Right side, right?
And he has a trampoline on Go Okay, second jump, second jump
Okay All right Go go go go go go go go go Okay, second jump
One Two Fox Fox What's this?
What's this?
Jump K2 How do we Oh, jump and hold jump key.
Oh, okay.
Goodbye I'm leaving guys.
Don't let go.
Guys, I'm leaving you guys
You're helping us get up there Look at this guys Look at
them getting carried by the giga chad that I am.
Oh, yeah, yeah straight carry We're just waiting Where are
we going?
Why did you?
Oh, okay.
I was like, why did you let go?
Who's this?
Oh, it's a car.
Let me drive.
Okay.
Let me drive, guys.
Oh, that's a car.
Yay.
We got to do anything, Zeno.
We don't have to.
It's RPR fault.
Yeah, it's RPR's fault.
We die.
RPR.
What are you doing?
Do you even have a driver's license of course i do who do
you think you are oh okay why are you like getting getting
hit by the thing it's literally like so big i'm i'm not hit
by anything do you see us passing you're like you're like
reading your chat while driving you should never text and
drive that's against the rules you need to close your chat
right now you see what you're doing do you want do you want
to fly on the map because i can make that happen right now
yeah but but you're just prolonging your madness.
You see this?
I got us here in three seconds.
Look at me.
Wait, wait.
My character's shish.
Wait, yeah.
What happened?
I didn't know.
Wait, guys.
What?
Oh, I don't like this.
Oh, we have to jump to the, when it rotates, we have to
jump.
Yeah.
Yeah, like follow the rotation.
It's like Fortnite.
I played this in Fortnite.
I did this in Twitch Rivals.
Fork Knife.
Battle Pass.
I can do it.
Oh my God.
You.
became a are you a woman or a no you're still well you
became younger or not i don't know i don't know you're the
only prehistoric dinosaur in here ducky oh my god hey i have
knowledge okay the older you get the more knowledgeable you
are maybe i was and i was over incarnated yeah you got
reincarnated are you guys ready three two one go go go go go
okay okay up okay keep jumping keep Keep jumping, keep
jumping.
Right side, right side, right side.
All up here.
What the hell?
Are you pulling me?
Back, back, back.
I'm not pulling you anywhere.
Stop climbing.
Go forward.
Okay, I got this.
I got this.
Okay.
I got it too.
And then we...
There we go.
I got it too, guys.
I figured it out as well.
Go left.
Okay.
Oh
Go right jump up here see it's also bad go left go left.
It's terrible.
Okay Uh-huh.
Oh, and then now we wait now wait now wait no wait wait wait
wait Sit on this ramp where you going sit in this ramp right
here What the hell you doing?
What the hell are you doing?
Oh my god, what is she doing?
Okay, go go go go go go go Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
What do you mean, what am I doing?
Just having a great time with my friends.
Go.
Yay.
See, it's not so bad.
I feel like we're doing really well compared to other
people.
Go.
I think it's just because we're gamers.
Are you guys ignoring me?
Go.
Yes.
I just wanted conversation.
This game should not just be GO!
Go!
We need to entertain!
I was focused on Upion.
Go!
And she falls.
The two rounds we tried to do conversation.
Our check cat just here, go!
We need other stuff!
Do you want to win or do you want to lose?
Okay.
I'm already winning.
Go!
Second jump!
Okay, second jump second jump.
Oh my god.
Okay, this way this way Okay, here we go now here comes the
pain train analyze analyze We jump left then we jump right
and then we go go go go.
Yeah, yeah left right left go Okay, let's just do this right
right there And then left left Yeah, you did it.
Okay, what is this button?
What is this button?
I don't know.
Oh, it's timed Oh, here, here, here, here.
I think we should do it.
No, no, it's time.
It has to be time because the music.
I think it's time.
Or not?
It's not?
There's no time.
We're going to wait.
We're going to wait longer.
But what if it's not?
Oh, okay.
It's time.
Okay.
Ready?
Go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Fast, faster, faster, faster.
Jumping, jumping only, jumping only.
No climbing, only jumping.
Stop climbing just jumping It's not even close...
Oh no, it's okay How close?
Yeah Go Yeah Yeah
go yeah I think it's because this game is not even hard how
are people struggling with this shit okay chat how about
this game this game isn't even hard this game isn't even
hard the biggest red flag ever dude guys how long is this
thing is it gonna come back i don't know i hope so i hope oh
there it is just came back yay all right yeah we're ready
all right how long is this game guys we need to know how
long is this game like an average completion rate according
to my calculations 45 minutes 45 yeah but that's a
speedrunner we're not speedrunner maybe we can do a Maybe we
can do a speed run.
Someone say five.
Someone was just like, yes.
We've done one out of ten.
This is one out of ten of the progress.
We have to swim?
How do we swim?
How?
Oh, control, control, control.
Control, control.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, control.
Please, I need a breathe.
Please, please.
Please, I will drown.
Wait, can you drown?
I don't know.
I'm going to try.
okay ditto go down three points it's the 3600 meters and we
did we did 500 we did 500 meters over 3600 meters so oh it's
3600 meters like 3600 wait then we're one fifth five ten
fifteen twenty one seven twenty five thirty oh what
we're one-fifth guys yeah it's closer now 500 meter okay 500
meter all right where's this we press buttons okay what now
okay okay we have to press all the buttons oh okay i guess
there's a timer of them wait right side right side is closer
go to the right go to the right okay okay Go here.
You don't have to jump there.
We can walk there.
No, we can't.
What are you doing?
What do you mean?
How do we walk?
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, this way, this way.
This way, okay, this way.
See, listen to Dino.
Dino knows what to do, RPR.
Come here.
All right.
And then what?
Up top?
Oh, we got pulled.
Oh, get up here.
Up here.
Ready?
Up top.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then we go to...
Yeah Right here.
See it's not that bad.
Oh my god.
It's not that bad.
Oh, it's Mario time.
It's Mario time Okay, be careful.
They're spiked.
Okay.
I'm dead.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We're pulling go up Come on up.
Okay, we're going to go up
Okay, this is bad.
This is really bad.
You know, can you like let go and It's flown over here.
Okay, okay, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Okay.
Get closer.
Why are you so far away?
Go, go, go, go, go.
Because we don't need to be that close.
What do you mean?
Yes, we do.
Maximum timing.
Okay, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm there.
Oh, we're so close.
It's fine.
It's so close.
Holy shit.
Alright, guys, I'm sure nothing's gonna happen.
Fuck!
Oh no, okay, okay.
I'm worried.
I'm worried about this.
He might need a 3, 2, 1.
Wait, what?
How did you do it?
Go next?
No!
RPR, why?
Wait, we can save this.
We can save this.
Why?
We're fine.
We're not even that far down.
Oh my god.
To be fair, that was very laggy.
Oh my god, that was not laggy.
I saved it twice and it kept teleporting me back in the air.
Somebody clipped this.
Somebody clipped RPR, fucking up again.
I did not fuck that up.
That was you guys.
How is, I was on the other side.
You see what they just did?
I was on the other side.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, we can't make change this again.
We don't need to coordinate.
We just need to use our eyes.
We don't need to coordinate this.
As long as our eyes work, we're fine.
All right, ready, get closer, get closer.
We gotta jump.
Okay, all right.
All right, here we go.
Okay, just use our eyes.
Just use our eyes.
We don't need to coordinate this.
He's a beast.
Oh, my God.
Why?
It's a beast.
It's okay.
It's a thing.
Okay, wait.
Come back.
There's a car.
We can literally run.
And then the car is more dangerous.
No, I'm a good driver.
Why didn't you use your eyes?
You did not need coordination for that.
You just needed to use your eyes.
No!
I'm getting off the car!
Get off the car!
Don't want to be the car!
I don't want to be the car!
It was easier.
Get off the car!
This is too close!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I swear to fucking god.
I swear.
I know people ride bikes in Europe, but like that was
terrible.
You would do better.
We don't need the car.
We can literally use our legs.
Like, it doesn't matter.
No, it's not.
What do you mean?
You see how long that trail is?
Oh, my God.
It doesn't matter.
The more time...
Go.
Okay.
Use your eyes.
Call me.
Don't push me.
Please.
Okay,
this one's easy.
This one's the easiest one.
Yeah, yeah, it's the easier one.
Pull me.
It's the easier one.
Go right, left side.
Okay.
We don't have the word.
This is the easier one.
Jump, jump.
Go left, go right.
I'm going left, I'm going left.
Go jump, jump, jump again.
Okay, I'm jumping.
I'm jumping.
Now go on the platform, platform.
All right.
Don't wait.
Hey.
Why are you guys still waiting?
What do you mean?
I made it.
I cut some time.
Go.
I can jump backward.
I've fallen.
Oh my god.
Up here.
Do not fall.
I swear to God.
Just keep falling.
I swear.
I'm falling.
I don't need to use go because it's so Go.
See, everything's fine.
Go.
Look at that.
We're team.
Go.
We're so coordinated.
Okay, second jump, guys.
Second jump.
All right.
And then two.
Go, go, go.
Okay, this one.
Okay, now we just go forward.
Okay, go.
Okay.
The next one.
Go.
Don't fall.
Okay.
Go.
The next one is the left one.
It's the left one right here.
Dito, Dito, where you believe me?
Dito, you gotta save it.
You gotta save it.
Dito, grab something.
I'm trying.
We're trying.
What do you mean?
Oh, my God.
That was not on me.
I was literally there.
I was there.
You two dragged me back down to hell.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yep, yep, yep.
Guys, we can't reset because somebody was like, no, we don't
need baby mode.
You think, uh, uh?
Yeah, yeah.
You think our chat would let us play baby mode?
You really think they would sign up for baby mode?
My dragons would let me play baby mode.
No, they wouldn't.
Read your own chat.
You don't know them.
Go.
All right.
Use eyes.
We don't need coordination here.
Just use your eyes.
Okay.
Oh my god, our PR is not using his eyes.
Why am I climbing backwards?
I am not using his eyes.
Okay, go, go, go, go, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump,
jump.
It's pink.
Okay, okay.
And then...
See, all of this is easy.
This one's so easy.
Faster.
What do you mean?
I'm literally faster than both of you combined.
Faster.
Look, I took that first.
I took that jump first.
Faster.
Pull me up.
Somebody's being a fucking...
Oh, pretty soon.
All right.
See, we made it.
Faster.
I don't think we need coordination for, okay, we need
coordination for this.
I don't think we, I'm dead.
I don't think we need to, yeah, I don't think we need to
jump that other box.
We can literally skip that one.
See, look, we are reading each other's minds.
We're reading our minds right now.
Okay, you guys need to be a little bit faster there.
Okay.
Alright, second jump.
Second jump.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Jump on the left one.
Okay.
Jump on this one.
I don't think we should have but okay.
Jump on next one.
Jump on this one.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
I press button we go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Jump, not calm, okay.
Guys, hurry up!
I can't get up because you guys keep fucking dragging me
behind!
about oh yeah i'm ahead of you i'm ahead of you i'm
literally ahead of you i'm literally i'm literally ahead of
you right now there you go okay okay see you are doing it go
okay we did it go
okay oh my god there we go everything's okay everything's
okay
she's like why are you guys pulling me back no one was doing
anything
i mean somebody was clearly pulling me back on my stream
swim how did you guys do it oh control i did it okay no swim
all i'm saying is that it was somebody's ping but it wasn't
my ping because i have the home advantage so you should be
carrying so why am i carrying them i was carrying but
somebody is a fucking cement block in my backpack maybe why
why do you keep falling i have a 250 wait how do you know
you don't we can't see our ping here I always...
Yeah, Apex.
How do you know?
Maybe the servers are better.
Oh, we don't have to do this again.
Thank God.
Oh, that's me.
Yeah, thank God.
Okay, okay.
Maybe there's better servers and chain together.
You don't know that.
Focus, focus, focus.
Okay, not yet, not yet.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, okay, time it, now,
okay, time it, now,
Dockies We can do this one by one We don't need a Stopping,
stopping One by one, yes One by one, yeah Okay Okay Okay
See, I told you One by one Slow and steady Okay, wait now
Wait now How the fuck Looking Looking Analyzing What?
We got this one The next one Oh, and then we jump on that
one You see that one on the right side the next one yeah
right side until then okay okay go go on this one okay okay
go now wait for next one which is next one okay okay that
one that one to the right to the
island okay yeah safe okay okay okay okay okay and then we
walk up the log don't fall off guys don't fall off don't
falling don't fall don't go oh my god there's all of us oh
my god we trained We're so good!
Okay.
Wait, this is easy.
This is easy.
Okay.
Go.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Go.
Oh, my God.
We all have to clap.
Go.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Double jump!
Why do it?
Pull it!
Okay.
Go!
Pull me, pull me, pull me.
Pull me.
Go.
Okay.
go all right i'm not go go oh it's fine it's fine this one
is so close this one's so close we can't pull each other
away all right and then we made it one minute breathe one
minute breathe one minute oh my god one oh seven one oh
seven okay wait how do we we have to walk up the sword is it
the sword yes yes yes but sword is moving no no no it's not
moving no it's dead my brain moving all right to the right
right yeah right go oh oh my god okay left left and go all
right and then we walk up oh this is easy this is easy this
is easy it's not as like no talking only moving yeah yeah
only move no no yapping only move okay um okay okay um
analyzing okay he walking weakly okay we walk walking
walking walking okay walking walking i feel like we've like
devolved into cavemen let's go jump back we're all careful
walking right now
yeah oh my god where are we going careful walking careful
walking okay okay i don't need careful walking the aqua
swimming i swimming i swimming okay but like how do we can
we drown i don't know no dying no dying we go right side
okay all right side the right side wait what's the go back
wait yeah up top up top wait how did you guys go down space
bar no this is this is dead end dead end why are you so bad
at with mazes what is this what is this for the first time
what are you it's nearly 50 50 how could you choose the
wrong 50 what are you guys doing oh you guys are too
Dito go up go up Dito Dito go up Dito Come on go up Dito All
right down And then we'd go up here I'm lying Doki lying And
then okay 50 50 which way I take left Okay And then we go
this That was a dead end I knew every time you let it give
us a dead end I let us to the right area My name is Dr. Bird
blah blah blah Guys guys guys your chains chains okay okay
we're fine we're fine oh see there you go i find i found i
find it we did it no i'm i'm on top first i find no no no no
what did you do what do you mean what did you do what do you
mean what did you do what did you do what did you do what
did you do what did you do what did you do what no it's not
no dokey dokey you swam into the work no i did not it was
not me It was not me.
What did you do?
What the fuck did you do?
Wait, we go in here?
Oh no, the top is the cars again.
It's the cars.
We have to do the car again.
Chat, chat, chat, chat, chat.
RPI, what did you do?
RPI.
Again and again and again.
See, she fucked up.
Why didn't you...
Did it?
Was it our PR's fault?
It is not our PR's fault.
We're both on our PR.
We saw it.
It was her not going to lie.
You're like, oh, I'm talking more, I'm running.
You dragged us down.
You pushed Doki.
Yeah, you pushed me.
Why did you push me?
We were so hard to do the main thing.
It's clipped.
It's clipped and it's shipped.
We're going to see it.
The whole world's going to see it.
Oh, it's not as far.
It's not as far.
You said you're doky.
No, it's pretty far.
I'm not doky.
It's pretty far, Dido.
We did a lot of stuff to get here.
No, it's not.
It's just, it's almost there.
What is it?
It's pretty far.
We have to do the, uh, the thing where like, the, the, the
running up the thing.
Yeah.
This one.
Running One by one one one by one one by one by one stopping
stopping One okay, okay
This is why we do one by one
going on this going on this okay it's on my fault you're
right this next one this next one this next one jump okay
okay okay okay okay jump on this okay okay okay next one we
jump on
Yeah, I wouldn't scream.
All right, this one.
Go.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Okay, casually.
Up here, please.
Up here.
Okay.
Ready?
Go.
Go, go, go, go.
Go, go.
Your voice raises up 10 octaves.
Go.
oh okay now everyone stop here look on your left this is
where doki fell through this hole you see above oh okay you
see this is where doki fell through no that's just the air
where's the hole what do you mean jump okay jump jump jump
come on guys jump we can do this faster jump we're not We
gotta be careful now.
We gotta be careful now.
I'd be unzop saying jump!
That is my fault that you pressed paste.
Right side.
Okay.
Boring.
Jump.
This one we don't need coordination.
We can just walk.
Jump.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay.
casual walking casual walking this is hard this is hard it's
it's like uh mario party the yoshi thing the yoshi crayon
never played mario party in my life look at me i'm a fucking
gamer look at me go i know stopping i know stop i think we
need to stop guys i think
All right, we remember how left side left side.
Yeah, left side left side left side left side this way this
way Okay, through the hole and then right side yeah left
left and then up up up and then was it right side Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Guys, I'm still...
Guys, give me a sec.
I'm still...
I'm stuck in a hole!
So slow!
Don't make me go in the hole again.
I will go in the hole.
Okay, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
All right, right.
Wait.
So we go through here and then we go...
We hold right...
Wait.
Look, look, looking.
Swim into the wall.
Okay.
Swim with me.
I'm swimming.
Okay, we go here.
We're going here.
We go up here.
Okay, okay.
And then we're safe.
We're safe.
Let's go left.
Oh, fuck.
Can we make this?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Coordination.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
Go.
Why did you guys not move?
Because it is Discord delay.
What do you want from us?
Oh my god.
Why did you jump?
None of us did jump.
I'm safe.
All right.
Here we go.
Are you still safe?
All right.
Okay.
Oh, what now?
What now?
What do we do here?
Wait, what?
I think I don't knowing.
Let's go slow.
How do we?
Can you crouch?
Yeah, we can't.
we can't we can't yeah how do we do this wait um oh one of
us has to fall and grip the other side i think okay okay but
we gotta stay still i'm gonna fall i will drop no i will
drop get closer come close to me come close to me
What if we just climb over?
I don't think we can.
I'll swing.
I swing.
You guys stay close.
No, you have to be on the pipe.
You have to be on the pipe right here.
Okay.
You both need to stand here where I'm standing.
But what if we die?
Okay.
Then we're dead.
I swing.
Why did you fall?
Please explain.
Dokey pool.
I couldn't fall.
Wait.
Save this, we can save this!
No!
Why did you guys fall?
Wait!
That was not me!
I stayed on the log.
Why did you fall?
No!
I was...
I was pulled.
There's no way... There's no way actually have to do do do
the swing straight right how can i swing well yeah i don't
know i don't know how to swing i don't know let me swing all
right are you guys ready uh-huh whoop okay you guys we're
not ready you guys we're not ready i can't anymore i can't i
can't anymore i can't she's strolling she's just strolling
right now no she's strolling
How's it being?
You guys wouldn't pull me back though!
You're the one swinging off the fucking air!
I didn't know what you're talking about!
I did my job!
We can't even figure it out.
What do you mean distribute?
Wait, we don't know how to do that shit.
It's stupid.
I'm not throwing!
Up here is just a bad idea.
I'm not even IGL.
Our fear of, oh no, Shido, what are you?
Oh my God.
Guys, please.
He's scat.
My toys were pink.
It was a ping.
Sometimes, sometimes I feel like it's not ping.
I don't know.
It's a ping.
Okay, Dan, why don't we create a server?
in asia why don't no no no no no no no no gray green pink
those hey guys what you doing i was just eyesways okay let's
not move here guys let's not go all right go go ah i went
too far i went too far i went too far
Pull me.
We're trying.
Oh my god.
We can literally go all the way.
I'm too strong.
Okay, we don't need to coordinate for this.
I feel like we know what to do.
Can you like not jinx us every time?
We made it.
We made it though.
I told you we didn't need it.
Second jump, second jump.
On two, on two, on two.
Going, go, go, go, go.
Going.
Okay.
Wait, waiting, waiting.
We're waiting, we're waiting.
This one, this one, this one.
Oip.
Okay.
And then hop, next, next, next, hop, hop, hop, hop, hop,
hop, hop, hop, hop, hop.
Okay.
I press, I press, I press, I press.
Going, going, going.
We should keep jumping.
Why are we still clapping?
Stop pulling me back.
You climbing.
No one's pulling you back, dumbass.
It literally shows on my screen that you're pulling me back.
You guys are dead weight.
Oh, my God.
I go without you guys.
Nice.
We did it.
We made it.
This is it.
I want to go right side.
We did it, guys.
We did it.
I want to go and bring you around.
the room
we get over here
what are you doing why are you not working as a team i'm
gonna do it where's the thing you sent it the way uh no i
didn't it's right here see we're almost there Where?
I jump off.
I will fall right now.
Up here.
Pull me.
Pull, yeah, I pull you.
Wait, how is he gonna make it, actually?
I don't know.
Pull me.
Pull me up.
Okay, he made it.
This way.
This way, this way.
This way, this way, this way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, guys, I don't think we're gonna beat this guys I
don't think we're gonna beat it guys I think the swing time
is pretty high The speed run for this is two hours and 30
minutes guys We're halfway there That's the speed run We're
halfway there one hour four minutes How do we swing How do
we swing?
We're both to find out.
Maybe doki go first and up here.
They were strong in my life to be honest.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll...
Doki?
Hey guys.
Hey, can somebody pull me?
No, only up here I can pull you, I think.
No, you can pull other people.
No, I can't only pull you.
I can't pull.
We should all be able to pull because we're open.
This is an open chain.
This is the easier chain.
This is the easier chain because we're an open chain.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Okay, RPR.
We're through slow.
Slow guy.
All right, down we go.
I'm ready.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I feel like I aged like 20 years playing this game.
Not gonna lie.
Jump, jump.
i feel like i feel like this game has taken some of my
lifespan one at a time ditto now you okay let ditto go first
let ditto go first let ditto go first no i'm dead i thought
i said you didn't go first no i go first okay ditto your
turn No, no, Dito, no, no.
Let her go first.
Just let her go first.
At least.
Dito.
Dito, you trolling.
Okay, you're both on the other side.
Wait.
Oh my god.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
I don't know how, but we did it.
Oh my god.
This one, this one, this one.
Oh, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Okay, here.
Okay, jump.
Laser, laser jump, laser jump.
Oh, oing.
This one, this one, this one, this one.
Okay.
All right, and in the sound, like, all right.
Okay, it works, guys.
How did you leave that thing?
It's okay in the end.
It just works.
Okay, three.
Jumping.
Oh, okay.
jumping okay go go go go jump all right the guy's screaming
okay it's because it's hell we're in hell of course we're
gonna be screaming no someone else is screaming yeah i know
but like yeah that's what i'm saying hell is just not us
three there's other people in hell like our chat are we like
climbing to heaven yeah we're trying to climb up in hell
we're not gonna go to Wait, what?
We can't.
What do you mean?
Why can't we go to heaven?
You don't deserve heaven.
Why don't we just go to the heavens at like a higher level?
Just a higher level of hell.
Yeah.
Oh, it's like the nine circles of hell.
We don't deserve heaven.
What do you mean?
I'm a good person.
No, only you.
What do you mean?
Only you?
The only reason why we're in hell is because of you.
You don't deserve heaven.
Yeah.
And because we're chained to you, we're forced to not be at
heaven.
Why are you chained?
LAUGHTER Pull me up Pull me up Duckiebird I couldn't I
couldn't Pull anybody Land on the island Land on the island
Why do you fail?
Go intellectual Gold Why do you fall?
See this is why we're in hell This is exactly why we're in
hell You keep falling To you guys You keep falling You fell
first and then you pulled first and then you pulled Ditto
down and then I couldn't do anything because we were on the
log.
We were on the log.
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
I did not fall first.
Ditto fell first.
I didn't fall.
I didn't do anything.
She is trolling.
No, you fell first.
You fell first.
I saw it.
Did I not tell you guys you fall?
That is not true.
You guys are lying.
No, we're not lying.
You are just in denial.
You're in denial.
Wash my POV You're in denial.
You fell first.
You fell first RPR.
I saw you.
No, you just you had you have to wash my POV up here.
Yeah, you have to watch my POV, too.
You totally fell first.
I saw it.
Yeah.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna.
What are you gonna do?
You're chained to us.
You can't do anything.
Okay, I don't want to move.
You guys pull me.
Okay, we won't move either.
Okay, okay, how we move here?
Okay?
Okay, the game?
I'm stronger than both of you.
What happened?
I said you weren't gonna move when I...
what happened better move or we die would you like to die or
would you like to move we die we won't have to play this
game anymore this was your idea by the way i thought it'd be
fun but i didn't realize how bad you'll be at the game rpr
you're worse than me and oh my god you're the worst one here
have i the worst one here we have ditto
Save it, save it, save it, save it.
That was pain.
Landed, landed, landed, landed.
Oh, Jesus, Maria, someone saved me from this hell.
Someone saved me.
Yeah, we had to jump from here.
Three, two, one, jump.
you jumped on two i'm gonna throw up
what happened okay i go first i get out get out i okay okay
okay this is on you guys i volunteer to go first i even this
big ones this big ones can do anything to us this big one
yeah all right yeah yeah that's what you're gonna say yeah
Yeah, what happened?
Huh?
What happened?
Sorry, I'm just too good at the game.
Nothing happened.
I'm just too good at the game that nothing happened.
It's really hard to throw, you know?
Uncopium.
It's so hard to throw when I'm just that naturally gifted at
that chain together.
You're naturally gifted at ruining your teammates' mental
health.
Wow.
Why?
Okay.
Can we cut this chain off?
I called your fucking bluff.
I wish there was a...
Yeah?
Yeah.
Oh my god, you're so dumb.
Get in the fucking car.
You have to get on it first.
Follow you.
I just follow you.
Yeah, we're just following you.
Yeah.
You jump down, so I jump down.
the leader oh my god i can't even fall like i can't fall i'm
too good at driving i literally can't
fall stop reading your chat while you're driving you're not
supposed to text and drive rpr you're setting a bad example
to everybody don't drink and drive kids oh no all right
let's do this again let's do this again yeah none of us are
gonna troll right right whoa i wish i could i wish there was
one chain you could like cut off by the game and then i'll
just cut off a chain a little bit from back home
okay ready okay ready okay ready ready
I'm ready special Yay Oh my god, you're getting us killed
How am I getting us killed?
This is the one that Better than all of you Yeah, because of
the ping Yeah, yeah, ping, ping Yeah, yeah, it's always the
ping Can't blame everything on the ping Okay, let's play on
my server then Oh yeah, sure, let's play on your server,
let's do it Yeah?
She's special I said let's go Go on my server, we lose all
of this progress, right?
fine we could do it all again on your server you stop
bluffing i'm not gonna take your bluff
stop bluffing you know you won't i will totally go on your
server i'm not bluffing i'll do all of this again just to
prove a point let's all the fort together then all right all
right i i can leave and this this this lobby will close jump
i'm not listen if you leave i'm not doing this all over
again why i thought we'll do it better on your server what
happened i would do better but you would do worse and you
already really bad so you can't do it let's prove a point
let's prove a point we'll play your server you're not gonna
you're not gonna sacrifice all this progress to I will.
I will.
I want to sacrifice.
It's 3.30 a.m.
I want to sacrifice all of...
I'm giving you 30 more minutes.
I'm giving you 30 more minutes to this game, and I'm going
to bed.
You're giving me 30 minutes?
Dingo's been streaming for 16 hours.
Whose fault is that?
I mean, that's...
Your fault.
How is it my fault that you're streaming for 16 hours?
Jump on this one.
Just jump when you stop complaining.
and jump first base I'm hearing again I'm hearing again oh
my god I'm hearing okay ready go guys I need you guys to
stop being so behind is that you're forcing me to climb I'm
literally behind you I'm literally pulling me back you're
pulling me back you are special you are special we made it
rpr you're so slow didn't i were in the front i'm going to
jump you did not make it to the box i'm going to jump yeah
because i got pulled who pulled you none of us came behind
me okay yeah okay rpr that last is a chain to me okay are
you including yourself are you no look red and orange i'm
green i'm colorblind what's that Green, green, green.
What does green look like?
I'm colorblind.
Not red.
Oh wait, so you're red.
What kind of colorblind are you?
It's like a really rare kind of colorblind.
I don't remember the name.
Apparently one out of a million kids get it.
I'm not at the bottom yet.
I need a swim.
You're so special.
You're one in a million special.
Yeah, I'm one in a million.
Look, see, we made it back, guys.
We did it.
This is not feel like an hour.
I feel like I've been playing this game for like four hours
with you, too.
We've been playing for four hours.
I feel like this has been four hours.
How is this only an hour?
I don't understand how this is.
For someone who's played before, you're not very good at
this game.
I'm carrying your dumbass Yeah, I'm literally pulling both
of you guys up.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
You're pulling me.
No, I see You're the one who failed you are yeah Yeah, yeah,
you're the one who fell and made us restart this entire part
I literally literally wasn't me like I'm done with this
gaslighting when we were swinging you fucked up You fucked
up the swing.
Okay, did it was gonna get hit.
Okay, no, she's not okay I'm fine.
I'm fine.
That was scary.
Press space.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is wrong with you guys?
That was not on me and you know it.
That was... Okay, me first.
Me first.
You gotta stay there.
She's gonna get in.
Now!
Where do you guys go?
Okay, Tiddo.
You're last.
Come on, Tiddo.
okay Okay, me first me first, me first, okay Okay Okay, did
it We did it Oh my god, she did it She did it all the time
She did it she did Oh my god, we fucking did it guys Ok,
jump.
Alright, pummel party!
Pump-up party!
Pummel party!
Jump this one.
Okay.
Jump the next one, right here.
Uh-huh.
Oh, my God.
I almost look like all three of us miss.
This one?
Jump?
Yay!
Jump down.
Okay, okay, okay.
Calm, calm.
Calm down, guys.
We don't have to rush this one.
We don't have to rush it.
Guys, please.
Who puts fucking glue on that shit?
You have to rush this.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, get back.
Okay, we're back again.
We've made it.
We're back to 500 meters.
No counting just going.
We don't need a count.
We can read each other's minds.
together for so long.
Yes.
Yeah, for sure.
It feels like five years have passed since we started
chaining together.
All right.
We don't need a sprint, guys.
We don't...
Time in hell flows differently, so it could possibly be five
years and we've known.
We could have, yeah, honestly.
This feels like it.
All right.
Up we go.
Up we go, guys.
Slowly, slowly, slowly.
falling no falling don't falling and don't falling allowed
we don't need a run we don't need a sprint for this we
literally good aim good aim only good aim yeah we're fps
gamers we don't we don't fall i can't go on okay no ditto
you cannot ditto don't you don't do it it's maze time it's
maze oh my god look at us we're so far oh my god we did it
again we're back here we did it we're back years have passed
since we started this game we've been stuck here okay i was
testing you guys i knew it was up there no you would not i
knew it was up there i wanted to make sure you guys knew it
okay we gotta hug the wall hug the wall so our pr doesn't
throw again dokey i am going to clip compilations already
for you after she what my clip combination your what
confirmation of me it's gonna be like last seconds long i
have more clips on you than you do on me go okay okay this
is the swing part guys this is the swing part oh the swing
part i think doki go for yeah i should i should be the one
swinging i should be the one swinging am i staying then
because i am middle yeah yeah um i i that's gonna go great i
should swing okay last time you swing what happened we only
almost died no you last time you you said we all died i
understand here i understand here okay are you guys ready
yeah yes okay try and coordinate this you did nothing okay
that's great okay rpr how is this my fault when she jumps
she pulls me down rpr wait wait wait um maybe it's like dumb
and dumber but you're both dumber oh but jump here oh no we
can't No, we can't.
No, listen.
Listen to it.
I'll show you guys physics.
I stay here.
Oh, stop.
Stop pushing me.
Come with me.
I stay here.
And both of you jump.
You're not going to be able to keep both of us up.
You're not going to be.
Yes, I will.
I'll carry.
Both of you jump.
One left, one right.
Okay.
I'll go right.
Go right, you go left, okay?
Three, two, one, jump.
Yeah, yeah, you see, you see mathematics.
Mathematics, do, do, do, yeah.
You see this shit?
Ditto, we did it, Ditto.
We're so smart, Ditto.
We did it.
Ditto, we did it.
Okay, second jump, second jump.
This one, this one, okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, second jump.
Second jump.
This is why I am the brain.
Where do we go though?
This way, this way, this way.
Third jump, third jump, third jump, third jump.
This way, this way.
Third jump, third jump.
You know how numbers work, Vito?
Third jump.
Number three.
One.
Okay.
Two.
Three.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, I thought you Oh my god, oh my god,
we're so smart.
We're so smart Someone clipped this shit Someone clipped
that shirt It was my idea Ditto and I we figured it out
together Yeah Come here come here.
Come here.
Oh, yeah No, your guys's idea was dock his idea was and I
quote I jump you guys wait and then we all fall with her no
because we didn't know i idea was i am the center of the
weights no we didn't fall you guys jump we'll swing okay
somebody's coping go somebody's and that's okay you didn't
take physics in high school and then we're gonna tell you
didn't even graduate what do you mean any graduate high
school i went to a fucking science high school Hello?
My high school was math and science.
Where's the diploma?
Where is it?
I'm not gonna show you.
I'm not gonna go to my fucking dumb actress.
Then you didn't graduate.
You probably fucking had two in fucking or what was that?
Dean fucking math.
Did you even pass physics?
Do you even know what physics is?
I did!
Did you?
Where's your proof?
You didn't even pass!
You didn't pass graduate high school!
Physics was the best subject!
The one?
The one!
one go physics was my favorite subject oh yeah laser 3 2 1
go okay this is pummel party this is pummel party okay okay
multiple times just jump multiple times just jump who did
that who did that who who who was it Now they're gonna say
it was my fault.
It was you.
I'm gonna say my fault.
I was- I was nowhere near laser.
I went forward.
I went forward, I went forward.
Me first, me first.
Okay, Dido.
Come on.
She's learning.
Me first!
Okay.
All right, nice, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
All right, we can just walk up for this.
We don't need a three, two, one, this.
We can see this and know where to do.
Okay, know where to do.
Guys, guys, guys, who's pulling?
Guys, who the?
Guys, jump here, jump here, jump here.
Guys, we need to jump here.
How are we gonna fucking...
This is a skip.
There's no way.
Wait.
I can't jump.
I can't.
I'm trying.
Just go down.
We need you.
I'm trying.
Just go down.
Get over here.
I can't pull her.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got it.
Just jump.
I'm trying to stay.
I can't pull her.
I can't.
You can't.
How do we...
What do you mean this is a skip?
This is a skip.
Listen to me.
I know what I'm doing.
Just come with me.
Okay.
I know the devs.
We know the devs.
Okay.
I do.
Okay, then what do we do then here?
Up here.
Yeah.
Trust me.
I know the devs.
Come.
Yeah.
Up here.
okay what do we do after that listen i know the devs you
don't trust me but i do know them okay how do we jump here
yeah yeah you see you see ditto did it yeah i did it and
then what and then what pull me okay okay okay now we go
here uh-huh you see this yeah yeah we're looking Yeah
I think somebody is coping I think we'd be at the top right
now I feel like we'd be at the top right now There's an
elevator here this way There's an elevator here.
I think the devs removed it.
Let's go back They remove it, trust me trust me.
There was... I don't think it ever existed RPR.
I don't think... I know the devs.
Do you know the devs too.
Yeah.
I know the devs too.
I know the devs?
No, you fucking don't.
No, you don't no, you don't.
How do you know I don't?
You don't know that?
Because they're my friends.
They don't know.
They're not my friends list right now.
What's your name?
They're not my friends list.
That is private information.
Oh, so you don't know.
You don't know.
What's the first letter?
No, no, no.
No, no.
I have them on my friends list.
I was the one that suggested the game because the devs
messaged me about it.
The devs emailed me and was like, you should play a game.
What's the first letter?
What's their name?
No, because I'm calling your club.
What's the first letter?
No, well, I'm calling you.
First letter was B.
Let's move on.
Yeah, the times they're going to ban you now because you
call them a bitch.
I hope they ban me.
I don't want to play this shit anymore.
Oh, my God.
This is a yes.
Okay, we go again.
20 minutes have passed.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna let go 20 minutes have passed it feels like so
many hours have passed oh my god please we don't need to cry
how can you you made this suggestion I didn't know how talk
should I be at this game you're so bad you're so much worse
than everyone what do you mean I'm so much worse look at you
look at you what what look who's the worst player did oh i'm
going yeah okay yeah well she's flying off the map while
she's holding my name while she's flying off the map yeah
i'm going without you guys no i got there first i would
touch this laser right now jk jump over to this one
Are you guys carrying me?
I'm pulling.
I go to.
Let's do the logs again.
We have to do the logs.
Oh my god.
Not this one.
Okay.
Jump.
Alright.
Well we're getting better.
We're doing this so many times.
We're getting better.
Yeah, we did this 12 times already.
and we weren't because if we weren't good it would be sad
please i know i heard there's a city there's a city above us
please i want to see the city i want to see the city i don't
want to be in hell anymore hell's nice it's nice and warm
it's like summer i know i wanted to be cold being having
yeah because it's not human that's the worst part about it
being warm is because it's oh my god you did this to us you
did i watched you do it why didn't you pull me up why didn't
you pull me up why didn't you pull me up he distracted me
with conversation i got distracted why didn't you give me a
conversation i was thinking about the
She starts the conversation, then she falls off, and then
she plays me for starting the conversation and distracting
her.
Stop!
You would have...
Oh my god!
You could kill her, please!
Why did you fall off?
Why did you...
I can't take this anymore.
I can't.
I can't anymore.
Fall off right now.
Come on, do it, you pussy.
Do it, you pussy?
Follow right now.
Oh my god.
This is torture.
You're not even a gamer.
You can be only up, but you can't even beat chain together.
That's so sad.
You didn't even beat all of them.
I did.
It's how my fault the VODs got deleted.
Spies from Doki's chat.
Come in my chat and tell me if she beat only up or not.
It's not my fault.
I beat it.
Okay.
She didn't beat shit.
I did.
I bet that person's not even a member.
I did it in a member stream so they missed out.
Same.
She did not, in fact, beat it.
I showed her membership right now.
It was in a member stream.
Member stream, my ass.
Member since day one.
She didn't beat the shit.
Why is it?
Call him out.
I'll recognize the name.
What's the name?
Wait.
Did Duggy play on the off?
Yeah, I did.
I did.
And I beat it.
You beat it too, right, Dido?
Yeah, I beat it.
Yeah.
So we all beat it.
So why can't RPR beat this game?
You did not beat OnlyUp, and I don't snitch.
Then you're lying.
You could be making it up right now.
I've been watching Docky POV.
I was membered, and I saw it.
People in my stream were like, I was membered.
I've been, let me read this.
I've been watching Docky POV this whole time.
Literally 90% of the falls are her fault.
That is not true.
That person, I bet.
Oh, my God.
See, I'm ahead of you guys.
Yeah, and you're going to get a skill as well.
Cool.
It worked.
She made that message up, by the way.
Oh, my God.
You're getting exposed.
You made one message up.
Wait, what?
The one you quote unquote read from your chat.
That's not true.
I literally looked at my message.
I remember the guy's username.
It was Wario.
He exists.
He's a real person in my chat.
Wario.
W-I-R-Y-O.
I literally saw it.
Not real.
You're not real.
And you made me fall.
Not real.
plus L that's on you that's on you it's your fun that you're
fucking terrible at video games other than apex you're
literally terrible at any game i'm a fucking multi-talented
multi-titled professional gamer in one yeah you're washed
now i've competed for 17 years i've been competing before
you knew what a pc was stop rolling you again it was you
again it was you again it was you more this is this is this
is saying earlier you were saying this stream can't be only
you saying go you have to go now i'm talking now you're
falling and now it's my fault yeah i'm glad we agree on
something i'm glad we finally agreed on something right that
is your fault yeah that is your fault that is your fault
you're the only person here i didn't beat on the app the
only person that didn't beat on i literally had someone just
super chat me was like i remember when doki beat only up
only took 30 minutes
that's true that was his fault he missed the jump and made
doki fall that is so true that is so true how did i miss the
jump i i grabbed the ledge
she made that super chat up by the way that is not true
dreds is a real person in my chat yeah i can also just pick
one name out of my chat and pretend they give me a hundred
dollars dude zikira thank you so much for a hundred dollar
bomb i've been watching yeah but don't be seen this entire
time so i know you know it would be more believable if you
talked about like like bitties because it's a twitch stream
bdj thank you for 10 gifted d it's dito's fault see like she
was she was Ditto Ditto is doing the best she can That is so
fucked up RPR Yeah, Ditto didn't do anything You're blaming
on her Guys, it's not me, it's the chatter That is so messed
up I'm just reading chat That is so messed up That you're
Farno, thank you for $10 Yes, I agree, Doki, Doki's always
That's so messed up that you're blaming Ditto She did
nothing wrong Yeah, Ditto's like actually the one
heart-carrying all of us us right now.
Your chat is toxic.
The deep talk that got hit by the windmill 14 times in a row
is coming.
I would keep it.
It's actually 15 times.
Look at this.
Look, I made it.
I made it though.
It's a speedrun tech.
Ditto is hard carrying both of us right now, RPR.
Why are you blaming her?
She's actually...
hard carrying us i even i even carried the swing i even
carried the swing we came up with the idea you could have
done the swing without us but you could have done the swing
without ditto and i yeah you can't yeah we coordinated the
right and the left if you came up with the idea then then
how uh how chat what is the reason chat told us how to do it
no no but what is the reason
It swung, jumped the right way.
That is the darkest shit I've ever heard in my life.
I swear to fucking die.
Okay, guys.
Don't pull.
Guys.
Why did you guys pull me?
Oh, my God.
Oh, is this all?
This is...
This is my favorite part again.
Okay.
Dokey.
for all i'm gonna explain the swing shot to you the reason
the swing shot works is because i am the middle and i am the
center of the gravity so if you two jump on each side i will
not fly off because equal weight will be distributed on both
sides you understand this no got it no i understand i'm not
stupid are you why are you talking to jinn and i as if we're
like children I'm not talking to you like your children.
I'm only talking to you like your children.
Get it right.
It's called a police system, RPR.
You don't even know the right name for it.
It's literally the police system.
The last four drops have been your fault.
That's not true.
That is not true.
This is a team effort.
We're chained together.
You just didn't like IGLS better.
Three times in a row.
Look what you're doing.
What you mean?
I'm like ahead of you guys.
What do you mean?
I'm literally ahead of you guys.
I'm literally made it.
Like what are you talking about?
I literally made it.
Chill out bro.
Yeah, no, I'm we are so...
All of us in here are so mad.
I'm so upset.
guys why you guys do this to me you agree to play this game
it still works it's still the works my dad owns youtube and
told me donkey's viewership is actually just one guy on 5
000 pcs
and that one guy is keeping it is carrying this game right
now he's giving us all the right information but his dad
owns youtube he gets really exposed for months now i have
yeah for months now i have fabricated your viewership by
creating thousands and thousands of accounts and now to
prove this point i will copy paste this message with all of
my accounts okay if he really wants to do that successfully
it has to be a short don't fall rpr don't fall rpr don't
fall it's easy guys don't fall Don't fall, IPR.
We saw that.
Yeah, but you see, when I fall, I save it.
You just fall.
No, I saved it, but then you pushed me.
Okay, okay.
You said yourself you can push this game.
Yes, you can.
At a certain point of the map, we didn't have to push
mechanic.
I know the devs and you don't.
And I know this.
I knew the devs.
You called the devs a bitch.
So, like, you don't have the permission anymore.
but you wouldn't know that because uh you're not tight like
that with devs like i am oh yeah what's your name i don't
know their nickname because we're tight like that with
homies oh yeah you don't know their names because you're
tight like that yeah then they're not homies then they're
not homies so what's their nickname their nickname is
there's there's there's guys there's guys i know on the
internet whose irl name i do not know and i know them for 17
years okay then you're not is homie you call you think
they're your homie but you're not their homie i've met this
person like seven times i yeah but you're not close enough
you're like an acquaintance then okay but give me one good
reason why i would need to know their name because you're
like you're like hey i need you i'm like hey uh i need i
need can you like can i see how you do your tax forms me i
need help with taxes can i see an example how you do your
taxes lucky let me explain something in europe right yeah
there's about 400 million countries and all tax forms are
different even if i knew his name what the can he do to me
to help me with my taxes when he lives in a different
country he could help you with calculations what do you mean
i can count i went to a math school
Why are you like this then?
Why are you like this?
I'm looking...
Three, two, one, go.
I literally fixed our swinging issue using physics and you
calling me dumb.
Can I remind you what your idea was again?
I'm swinging.
It was you.
You built off my initial hypothesis to get to your...
I jumped, guys.
And then it's going to happen.
Okay.
Fuck, man.
I go right.
You ready?
Three, two, one, go.
All right.
Just go forward.
Go forward.
Okay.
We did it, Tito.
Yes, nice.
Nice.
wait a second okay one two oh my god the math student knows
how to count one one two two all right we did it guys nice
oh my god everyone's spamming the copy past that now oh my
god i can't even read it anymore that's okay rpr chat you
come to mine or ditto's chat to have a good chatting
experience You sent in your spies to destroy my chat.
Ready?
Go.
We did it, guys.
Where did we die?
I don't know, go.
I think we see it, wasn't it?
Yeah, it's right here.
You see the lasers?
Three, two, one, go.
I see the lasers, guys.
Okay, slowly, slowly, slowly, slowly.
Right here.
Wait, did we die at the lasers?
Yeah, we died at the lasers.
Yeah.
three two one go guys i'm scared let's come up with a
strategy three two one go okay strategy we go we run you
stupid we run until the middle and then we jump you know
what let's just wing it let's just wing it fuck it three two
one go jump Jump.
We did it.
I'm so smart.
You said you are not smart.
You literally said.
What a hate.
Why did it just take down?
Because we don't need that anymore.
Three, two, one, go.
But you fall.
They don't literally clutch it for us.
They don't literally clutch that.
Guys, I just did everything, and I still got zero credit.
They don't clutch that for us.
was like let's wing it that is your plan some fucking math
science dude that said just wing it i just did everything
and i got zero credit yeah just like what you did everything
we needed everything we made it to the subway because of
ditto at least credit ditto for her hard work you can't say
wing it that claim credit for everything but i was the one
that said how we're gonna wing it ready to jump here yeah
three two one go oh we did it we come we come here yeah just
slow and steady guys slow and steady this is just jumps
go go go go guys guys guys you doing did okay okay three two
one go hey guys don't fall please don't fall please don't
fall please don't fall please
no guys no come on please Okay, I will admit that was the
first mistake I've made today That was the first mistake
I've ever made today I am I am willing to take the blame for
the first mistake She said that was the first It's down
there, it's down there, I see it Guys, guys, we're not doing
all that again We're not.
I'm not I'm not I'm not doing all that again.
It's all the way down there Here this way.
This way this way.
I see the right.
Yeah, you see it?
Right.
Yeah.
Yeah, I see it.
It's right here.
You go.
Yeah, let's go.
Jump.
Oh, wait Ready?
Yeah, where we're jumping to the right to the in front of us
three two one go
For it here, okay, and jump again to the cross jump to the
cross here to the cross dude okay two one go go there we go
see we're doing it guys okay see at least i am an adult and
i can admit when i up oh okay every single time you've
fallen you've said somehow we pushed you or pulled you or
more made you distracted So every time you've fallen, it was
our fault, even though you fell.
No, no, no.
It wasn't your, it wasn't everybody's fault.
It was your fault.
Uh-huh.
Ditto was innocent.
I don't know why you keep dragging Ditto into this argument.
Yeah, I know.
She has not done anything wrong.
Yeah, yep, that makes everything so much better.
Yeah, we're doing it, guys.
Teamwork.
I remember this.
Teamwork, guys.
Next fall, I'm going to bed.
I'm not even kidding.
It's 4 a.m.
Guys, please.
Guys, guys.
Guys.
Teamwork.
Teamwork, guys.
All right, I'm going to hug the wall.
Next fall, next fall is bed.
Okay, next fall is bed.
It's 4 a.m.
Okay.
But what if you're the one...
All right, whoever falls is the reason why we're losing.
no no yeah all right whoever falls is the reason one go all
right are we gonna beat this game you're in the most
dangerous you know that are you ever gonna beat this game
guys no i'm gonna install it after this guys you're gonna
hit 600 guys okay do you think we can hit a thousand okay i
want to see the Okay, ready to go?
Three, two, one, go.
I invented this shadow.
Oh, yeah, you invented the police system.
Yep, I invented that.
Oh, one.
One.
One?
Two.
Okay.
There you go.
One.
Two.
Okay.
We did it.
Yay.
We're doing it, guys.
Okay.
I'm a little worried that we're not calling the jumps for
this.
Why?
It's small you.
Every jump matters now.
All right.
What the fuck?
How did I get pulled up there?
These are easy jumps.
Easy jumps.
Yeah, easy jumps.
Three, two, one, go.
Easy jump.
Walking, walking, running, running, running.
Alright, easy jump.
Oh, RPR, I thought it was easy.
RPR?
I thought this was easy.
You guys pulled me.
How did we pull you?
3, 2, 1, go.
No complaining, just jumping.
Okay.
3, 2, 1, go.
We wing it.
Now.
Jump.
Three, two, one, go.
three two one go three two one go okay okay we got it we got
it we got it okay two one go yay okay okay okay this is
where we fall this is where we fell okay slowly slowly
slowly jump over laser jump over laser Okay, now we count
here, okay?
Three, two, one, go.
Okay, we're dead.
I'm dead.
Pull me faster.
Pull me.
I'm pulling.
She's not pulling.
You both have to pull.
Dito, don't pull.
Don't fall.
Dito, do not fall.
Dito do not fall.
I'm pressing.
I got you.
Okay.
How the fuck are we going to do this?
I saved you guys.
Remember what I did.
How are we going to win?
How are we going to do this?
No.
You always said wing it.
Fuck it.
Let's just follow me, okay?
Okay.
We go.
Now.
Jump Jump again Just out the board Just out the bridge No We
didn't fall the way down though we can do this again No I'm
not I'm fucking done no more no more That wasn't me I know
for sure that wasn't me who was it Who the fuck was it who
touched it Who touched it RPR Did you touch it?
That one was that one was hard as fuck How do you beat that
one?
That one was hard as fuck.
How do you not touch the laser dude?
By the way, it was all of us.
All of us got to admit the same one.
It was the all of us.
I was on the other side.
Oh my God.
Yop, yop, yop.
Not my fault.
My name's Yaki, but I told you.
I made, I admit my mistakes.
You didn't admit your mistakes.
Jado and I both admitted when we fucked up.
I said it was all of our fault there.
I scoot in.
I'm sorry that I'm a perfect human being and just don't make
mistakes.
I'm sorry.
She did.
We all made goodbye.
I don't make mistakes.
My bad.
I mean, my bad.
Let's look at everything that we did today, guys.
Look at the beautiful scenery.
Look at the beautiful.
This is everything.
We actually went up quite a lot.
Like, look how much we went up.
It's so beautiful.
Wait, jump out to the middle.
up jump into the map no we can't really block the hell sucks
dick this is so beautiful that's us right there stop yeah i
wish that was me right now wait those those people are too
big what the oh my god wait you're right what the fuck how
big are these people i'm glad i'm glad are you gonna end it
like guys are we ever gonna beat this guys guys are we gonna
beat this game guys yeah you want to go for round two guys
are we gonna beat it you want to go for round two on this
yeah i'm down just the way you're down what the you're a
quitter you're a coward dinoa and i can are down for it all
right let's do it then you're a coward you're a quitter all
right let's do it then all right yeah let's do it let's beat
this game not now next time yeah guys i'm not stream i'm not
gonna stream it guys i'm not gonna what do you mean you're
not gonna stream what do we beat this off stream yeah we'll
beat it off stream i'll just give the controller to my
brother yeah yeah same vibe like what the fuck yeah let me
and dm the speed runner for the speed runner oh my god okay
so you know how this higher speed running team and then we
asked them to change their names to our name and then like
record it and then we voice act it that's more effort than
actually beating the game no it's not because for them it
only takes two hours it only takes two hours to beat the
game but you have to voice act the two hours of the yeah but
we can just stream it we streamed them play one of them
screen share we take their screen share and play it while
we're voice acting you just told me a quarter and this is
your shot in the bidding game they'll never know they just
have to copy our names they'll never know you see this would
have worked if you didn't say the entire game yeah but like
but then what if that's just a bait that's just a base so
now they'll never know like if we're actually playing it or
not maybe we didn't play this entire time and yeah maybe we
didn't play this entire time maybe we already hired the
speedrunners chat yeah and they were falling for two hours
yeah because they want to make it believable yeah that's why
they didn't even get to one we didn't even get to half of
the map because they want to make it believable because they
think we're that fucking dumb yeah our voice acting we were
just showing off our voice acting they're saying we're gonna
need a hand cam next time
oh we did it guys guys we beat the game that's why we're in
the beginning if we're watching now we beat the game and
that's why we're at the beginning of the map one hour 59
minutes and 27 seconds new world record by the way round of
applause for me yeah for ditto and i for me for caring yeah
next time we're gonna do it blindfolded all for yours oh
this does not feel like two hours this was the longest two
hours of my life i felt like i've been playing this game for
like eight hours
how long how long have you been live ditto let's see yeah
how long you've been live ditto 15 hours oh my god go to bed
go to bed yeah you guys go to bed i was playing palmo the
reason we stopped playing is because ditto has to go to bed
like we're just being considerate otherwise otherwise we'd
be the game we would beat the game if she didn't have to go
to bed but she has to go to bed so we can't beat the game
yeah yeah exactly guys we have to stop because ditto has to
sleep now guys that is why we didn't give up we just had we
were very considerate over ditto's sleep schedule because
she's been out for like 15 hours now so um because of that
we're stopping because we care about ditto and we wanted her
ahead playing as a duo then yeah okay we can't play without
ditto yeah we can't play without ditto the same i want to
watch you guys we're a trio it's like apex legends we're a
trio we're we're slightly manhara team slightly manhara we
can't be like manhara without ditto
without ditto we'll just be like not manhara which would be
terrible you guys more like manhara than me you're the one
that streamed 50 hours that's menhara behavior right I'm
wasting precious minutes I could be sleeping precious
minutes are being wasted look at me press out the fork we're
looking oh I'm not there I'm not there I'm gone I'm I'm
already good.
GGs, guys.
I had a great time playing with you guys.
I can't wait.
I can't wait for our next one.
Yeah, I can't wait till we beat this, right?
We're gonna beat it.
We're gonna see the city.
Yeah, next time we should bring Uto.
Next time we should bring Uto.
Okay.
When we're struggling as three, as four, we're not gonna get
past the car.
Uto is gonna get mad.
Yeah, Uto is gonna get so mad.
With four people, there's one more person to carry.
Wait, how are you gonna do the police system with four?
Two people stay in the middle and two swingers.
It works the same way.
No, no, we just go with a light.
Because there's more weight on the center.
Two go left and two go right.
That's that's easy.
Would it be like two go left and you went to science school?
We are not gonna fall.
If there's two people the center then the weight
distribution will pull to the right yeah yeah you went to
the science school that's not physics oh my god i told you
you can graduate this is this is a great time great time
guys i see you guys for the next i'm gonna talk to my
dragons cheese cheese guys bye bye bye bye bye bye oh i'm
tired i'm so tired all right i'm gonna figure out why my my
my goxlr for some reason was not was like so quiet today
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna oh my gosh what the fuck is that
sound what the fuck oh sorry i had an ad i was like oh my
god i was like my phone played the ad okay i'm gonna call it
here tgs i'll be at afcon tomorrow well tomorrow for me i
don't know dates right now i'm gonna mess at the moment but
i had a great time oh yes had a great time as always as
always everybody say hydrated posture check it i've been
moving around to get that blood flowing If you sit up for
me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.